ein wunderschöner morgen wartet uns hier
in unserer kleinen süßen mannschaft
fällt um meine lieben freunde wir haben
vor heute unfassbar viel auf der
to-do-liste denn heute und dass sie die
bereits im titel eingeblendet findet
endlich die insel reparatur 20 statt ich
habe unter der erste insel reparatur
folgende menge kommentare gelesen die in
die richtung gehen
luca avastin wie nur in der mine die
ganze zeit du hast überhaupt nicht so
eben die reparatur mäßiges gemacht
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht wir
schieben jetzt direkt eine zweite in die
reparatur folge einfach hinterher in der
wir uns heute wirklich auch mal mehr um
die insel kümmern werden von daher
natürlich erst mal ganz kurz meine items
dann fangen wir an
[Musik]
zwar würde ich sagen dass wir erst mal
mit dieser insel hier vorne anfangen
denn da habe ich mir ein paar sachen
überlegt die ich doch noch mal verändern
wollte wir fangen direkt an mit diesem
fenster hier an der seite
das finde ich mich ein bisschen doof
dass das hier an der seite geöffnet ist
das möchte ich nämlich eigentlich lieber
so haben dann sieht sie ein bisschen
schöner aus wir haben nicht die wand
direkt an der seite und auch wenn man
von innen reinkommt sieht man schon beim
lied ein bißchen mehr aus wie ein
fenster als nächstes habe ich mir
vorgenommen dass ich noch mal eben kurz
auf das haus hier darauf gehe und zwar
das einfach kurz hier von hier von der
seite und das hier noch mal eben kurz
abbauen beziehungsweise so tief setzte
dass ich hier ein lagerfeuer hinsetzt
und darauf die bruchsteinmauer dann sind
das ganz draußen nämlich so aus könnte
ein schornstein
dann wollte ich die beiden häuser da
auch noch die betten reinsetzen habe ich
mir gerade schon aus dem anderen haus
geholt und diesen räucherofen hier
wollte ich mitnehmen
den sehe ich nämlich auch eigentlich er
da vorne und der passte auch eigentlich
ganz gut bei werder schon alles klar
egal wir haben ja hier an der seite
schon den schornstein jetzt deswegen
könnten wir halt theoretisch habe ich
mir gedacht hier unten sackt das
wegnehmen hier den räucherofen einfach
hin dann sind das auch vielleicht ein
bisschen jahren überzeugende aus mit dem
schornstein und dann setze ich jetzt
einfach mal die betten hin dann machen
wir hier eher das gelbe doppelbett und
auf der anderen seite nehmen wir mal das
weiße band und platzieren das nicht hier
unten da nämlich auch geschrieben luca
das sieht echt nicht gut aus wenn das
hier damit der treppe runter geht
deswegen werde ich hier den boden auf
jeden fall nochmal wegnehmen um generell
alles auf diese höhe setzen nicht auf
dass sie deutlich ansprechender aus dann
kann man nämlich hier das bett hinsetzen
dann nehmen wir jetzt mal unsere
ich hab die steinstufen nicht
mitgenommen und zwar hier sondern kein
tisch mit einer kleinen laterne auch
drauf dann nehmen wir hier unseren
blumentopf mit dem mond sack und hier
den mond einfach mal hier rein gesetzt
und hier vorne können wir beispielsweise
auch noch ein fass entstellende wurde
auch in die kommentare geschrieben luca
du kannst da auch einfach ein kompass
dahin stellen da könnte man hier vorne
noch im feld macht und das ist nicht die
nächste aufgabe was ich mir gedacht habe
wenn ich da vorne mich das feld habe und
einen komposter wird mir geschrieben
dann ernten die villiger für mich
irgendwie das brot und so ich habe keine
ahnung da kann ich auch mit den traden
das sollte sich eigentlich ganz gut an
deswegen gehe ich immer ganz kurz rein
die man noch ein bisschen samen mit wir
können immer verschiedene sachen dann
pflanzt und einfach mal gucken was da
hinten an so wächst den platz haben wir
auf jeden fall das ist jetzt eine
künstlich angelegten insel von uns die
wir auch normal erweitern können aber
meine insel die ihr grenzt wirklich
schon ans ende
ich werde hier vorne jetzt auf jeden
fall alles mit dieser spitzhacke zu
ackerboden machen zeigt hier vorne noch
und hier die reihe machen wir auch noch
mal so ein bisschen
und dann können wir hier einfach mal so
ein bisschen weizen an pflanzen hier an
der ecke dann nehmen wir jetzt
beispielsweise mal die kürbiskerne die
komplett so hinsetzen und dann wachsen
hier kürbisse und hier vorne auch dann
nehmen wir doch mal die melonen kenne
das jetzt mal genauso hin
dann sollten die auf jeden fall
aufwachsen denke ich und die rote beete
sagen ich hab keine ahnung was mit rote
beete machen wollen und die kann ich ja
jetzt mal so im setzen das sollte
eigentlich passen ich bin gespannt ob
ich ihnen was falsch gemacht habe aber
der boden wird auch bewässerte denn wir
haben ja von unten wasser
was sich auf der villiger insel hier
vorne auch noch machen wollte war das
hier vorne drin in dem linken gebäude
dieser block durch einen baumstamm
ersetzt werden sollte und der hier nokia
ist nach außen sichtbar okay dann muss
ich den auf jeden fall jedoch soll das
habe ich gerade noch so ein bisschen
gibt schräger das hatte ich mir
aufgeschrieben
dann nehme ich mir jetzt mal hier
verschiedene setzlinge zum beispiel hier
vorne richtig mit einer kerze ganz schön
voller machen jetzt einfach mal sagt da
haben wir hier so ein alter perfekt
perfekt so über das feld alter
vielleicht sich das ausgezahlt wenn das
so extra gewesen wäre vieles in bei 40
minütiger wir müssen auf jeden fall
grasser durchziehen also hier vorne
reichen setzlingen der wächst bitte
jetzt auch ziemlich das ist ein ihren
baum drehte ich mittlerweile schon mit
bäumen für den baum habe ich jetzt mal
ein bisschen mehl hinten geholt sagt er
wechselt auch ganz hier vorne setzen auf
jeden fall noch eine eiche hin die finde
ich auch mal ganz schön davon haben noch
fast gar nichts deswegen hier bitteschön
reichenborn jetzt hinter der schule geht
so ein bisschen sogar das haus übernimmt
haben wir so ein bisschen auswahl mit
den bäumen der richter dass das wahnsinn
hier kommen mit dem schatten dass er so
ein bisschen chillen wie kann ich
eigentlich was sehen durch meinen helm
den baum hier vorne werde ich auch
nochmal ebenfalls sack und den erd-
blockieren nämlich auch noch mit denn
die bauminseln ich weiß nicht wie es
heute schaffen aber die soll auf jeden
fall auch noch kommen und zwar nach
vorne zusammen mit dem strandhaus aber
warum schnitzen oder von unseren
wasserfall ihr hoch er dann hier an der
seite lang
ich weiß nicht am hoch
[Musik]
vorne nämlich mal auch noch eben mit
daraus können wir uns dann wieder ganz
entspannt ein bisschen papier machen
ich weiß nicht warum ich mit allen
tieren und bewohner der insel sofa
scherz habe ich will den rheinbrücken
das leben hier bringen naja was sagt ihr
dazu kleinen schildkröten vega lass mich
einfach in ruhe man ich freue mich
einfach so krass darauf wenn diese
village einfach auf der insel nebenan
du kommst als erstes mit ich weiß nicht
ob der tod nach vorne sondern ehrt blog
braucht damit er so eine kleine treppe
hat oder so aber das kann ja nicht so
schwer sein der muss auch ganz einfach
nur da hoch schwimmen kommt man hier
zeigt er machen was halt so also du
gehst jetzt darauf auf dem blog und dann
gehst du hier hoch okay kommt hier drauf
und hier hoch
[Musik]
geht doch zack zack so würde die nummer
eins ist da drüben das war ja ganz kurze
time natürlich die anderen wohnung
[Musik]
nein
ich habe alles gemacht gegen das sie auf
gemacht dass er dadurch kommen dass sie
abgebaut oder sind arbeitstisch
doch dann hat sich eine idee die sonne
geht und sich anstrengen
du bist in meinem bett wir sind fertig
mit dem dinge vorne mit der widder insel
ich lege mich dann einfach mal ganz kurz
geschlafen und wir machen weiter mit der
nächsten aufgabe meiner liste denn den
kompletten sand auf der insel auf einer
ebene bringen und damit fangen wir
erstmal hier vorne an denn ich möchte
dass zwar am rand der insel sand ist das
finde ich ganz schön so strand mäßig
allerdings finde ich dass jeder block
der höher ist als der wasser das wasser
level das muss einfach erde sein weil da
hat man viel mehr möglichkeiten ganze
blumen drauf setzen da kannst du graz
und so kannst du dir anfangen sie ich ja
ich meine das andere wird sich einfach
mal hier vorne die erde hin dass ich
jetzt gerade noch so ein bisschen
provisorisch aus aber das wird auf dauer
wirklich sehr nice aussehen dass genau
das gleiche mache ich jetzt auch noch
mal hier vorne eben und hier an der
seite werde ich dafür aber auch im
gegenzug hier die erde einfach mal
mitnehmen hier dann nämlich zandt
hinsetzen und sieht ein bisschen schöner
aus und das hier werde ich jetzt auch
mal komplett ändern und ich glaube ich
mache euch so dass ich das nicht mit
einem happs machen sondern ich stelle
mich hierhin ihr schaut euch das hier an
und ich mich quasi einfach einmal so
decker 20 minuten habe ich das hier
gerade gemacht ich hab da hinten die
halbe insel abgebaut und hier sieht auch
schon hier im inventar wie viel sand ich
hier gerade abgebaut habe aber ich habe
das jetzt alles so gemacht wie es mir
vorgestellt habe also der untere blog
auf meereshöhe ist immer sand und alles
darüber dass erde
und das finde ich eigentlich ganz schön
denn jetzt gerade sie ist natürlich eher
ein bisschen aus wie kacke aber wenn das
jetzt alles grün wird und dann hier mit
dem gras auch so richtig vernünftig
bewachsen ist dann sieht das alles
zumindest mal ein bisschen einheitliche
aus dem baum ideen habe ich noch nie so
richtig verstanden den werde ich jetzt
auch mal ganz kurz noch fällen dann
stört er uns in zukunft auch nicht mehr
wie gesagt das hier machen wir heute
auch noch fertig die bahnstrecke das
wird eine ganz ganz große insel
reparatur folge ich freue mich mega auf
den fortschritt hier habe ich auch noch
alles rum gezogen und was ich auch noch
gemacht habe war hier das beim zucker
bochums weitere sportliche die höhle auf
zugebaut denn was ich mir gerade so
erlebt habe war wenn wir das häuschen
hirai balu schuldig wenn wir das
häuschen hier eh nicht mehr nutzen
können uns auch einfach hier theoretisch
ein weg runter baut
freuen können sich auch einfach ein weg
runter bauen unsere höhe und dann machen
wir einfach so einen gang herunter ich
nehme jetzt mal einfach beispielsweise
ein bisschen bruchstein zack zack zack
zack und dann brauchen wir jetzt auch
leid
dazu können wir uns jetzt nämlich
einfach die leitern nehmen hier
natürlich erstmal alles wieder zu machen
so dass sie wirklich niemand auf die
idee kommt raus zu kommen weil das war
immer so ein bisschen das problem dass
hier aus der höhle die ganzen dingens
her kamen die ganzen monster auf unsere
insel also wir hier mitmachen das weiß
ich noch nicht so richtig wenn die tipps
dafür habt dann schreibt es mir gern und
in die kommentare davon lebt er das
projekt das in mir sagt was ich machen
soll und ich auch hier ganz kurz noch
mal eben die ja da ab beziehungsweise
kann auch im kurz meine schaufel nehmen
geht es ein bisschen schneller hier
nochmal bruchstein hin
der bub stand habe ich nicht also ein
müsste ich mir noch im kurz holen hier
vorn mein gott das haben wir nicht
gesehen dass das haben wir nicht gesehen
das schaffe ich heute alles nicht mehr
ich brauche mich hier auf jeden fall
hoch und kann mich einfach so sagen dann
geht es runter in die höhle dann sind
wir hier
ja genau das war auf jeden fall meine
idee noch hierfür das hier möchte ich
generell so ein bisschen als lagerraum
nutzen ich glaube ich habe hier oben
sondern auch so ein paar teams drin
sogar und dann können wir hier einfach
auch so ein bisschen kisten reinmachen
und schlussendlich die ganzen winter
vorne auf unserer insel haben die
canucks kopien geht
ich gehe allerdings machen
kurz wieder hoch in meinen baumhaus und
die eine runde schlafen hier fehlt auf
jeden fall eine laterne fällt mir grad
auf das jetzt erstmal provisorischen
fackel hin
wir gehen können denn ich habe ganz ganz
ganz ganz viele pläne noch auf meiner
liste
und zwar plan nummer eins dafür bräuchte
ich einen eimer ich weiß nicht ob ich
den hier irgendwo habe oder noch nebenan
ich hab da nebenan genau das ist
wirklich bitter notwendig dass wir die
ganzen kiste mal vernünftig sortieren
und habe ich hier vorne noch nicht
einmal drin ist kein reimer und zwar
dass ich euch auch erstmal noch ganz
kurz sagen kann war dass ich hier vorn
den weg ein bisschen besser gemacht habe
hier das sieht jetzt deutlich
entspannter aus die mit dem runtergehen
dann kann ich auch immer zack zack zack
hier machen
hier geht es dann weiter runter der
stall hier kommt der ewig wie geht's
hier eigentlich
weil sie auch nicht wie das passieren
konnte
hier geht's auf jeden fall jetzt
vernünftig hoch und runter wie hier an
der seite das wächst hier alles das
kommt schon noch mit der zeit da werden
wir uns alle daran gewöhnen denke ich
ich hoffe ganz kurz mal eben den fisch
reimer hier vorne raus beziehungsweise
nicht fisch einmal aber jetzt wisst ihr
schon was ich vorhabe und zwar hatte ich
hab in einer der letzten folgen gesagt
dass ich ihn mir auf jeden fall einige
fische in den see setzen möchte und
dementsprechend kann ich das jetzt auch
wie gibt sich dementsprechend kann ich
jetzt auch hier endlich mal die sachen
so ein bisschen weg machen also wieder
insel habe ich geschafft in der
reparatur findet gerade statt fisch
einmal von jobs hatte der mir noch
gesagt bahnstrecke freunde für schwein
finden hast lust da guckst du plötzlich
wir nehmen auf jeden fall die
wassereimer und ich schaue jetzt mal
ganz kurz wo wir hier unten vielleicht
irgendwelche fischer haben hier vorne
genau das sind fische da schwimmen wir
jetzt mal eben kurz hin und dann können
wir nämlich einfach den wassereimer
nehmen auf seinen fisch rechts machen
dann sehe ich schon taktische fischen
ich werde jetzt auf jeden fall mal hier
vorne in unseren serien setzen
und zack und jetzt haben wir drei
verschiedene fische drin und können hier
und taschen und abhauen
ich weiß es nicht wir müssen uns nicht
ablenken lassen müssen wenn wir dürfen
uns nicht ablenken lassen denn die
nächste sache die bei mir auf dem plan
steht jetzt heimat geworden
ich wollte hier erstmal diesen ganzen
fluss außer ein bisschen mit steinen zu
kleistern dass ich mich dann auch ein
bisschen schöner aus bevor wir
allerdings dazu so richtig kommen möchte
ich auch erst mal eben mich hier
untergraben denn wir haben auch hier
unten noch eine situation am start
die uns so nicht gefallen kann das ist
nämlich die ganz alte formen ich weiß
nicht ob da überhaupt noch daran
erinnern könnt aber das war einmal eine
erste farblich so richtig gebaut habe wo
ich mich noch zu sehr von so leute
irritieren lassen niemand du brauchst
eine automatische farben und so griffen
am schnellsten was zu essen
nee nee das war nicht mein ding das war
nicht mein ding deswegen wird das sie
natürlich auch selbstverständlich alles
zugebaut zack zack mich wirklich nicht
wundern wenn ihr gleich irgendwie
pappschild oder so hier vorne rum hier
um die ecke zack jetzt aber niemand da
können wir alles zu bauen da können sie
mich auch den ganzen land macht wir
verwenden die ich von meiner insel
abgebaut habe so hier haben was zu
gebaut beziehungsweise den oberen knopf
er setzte noch mal ganz kurz eben durch
erde
dann haben wir das nämlich auch zu
gemacht was mir auch geschrieben wurde
war luca hier vorne ist auch dieser raum
ich weiß nicht mehr genau wo der wahl
ich glaube irgendwo hier runter oder so
und dort haben wir wohl auch irgendwas
vergessen zuzubauen hier sehen wir schon
poppelsdorf das heißt irgendwas habe ich
hier auf jeden fall zu gebaut aber der
war noch nicht komplett zugebaut glaube
ich oder doch komme hier jetzt auch noch
ganz viel platz also hier müssten auf
jeden fall auch noch alles ein bisschen
zu bauen ich hoffe einfach ihr seid mit
dieser insel reparatur folge jetzt
zufrieden denn mehr insel reparatur geht
wirklich mich also dieser ganze raum
jetzt auch zu hier vorne kommt natürlich
auch wieder nähert block heraus dann
haben wir das hier auch zu hier vorne
passt alles ich glaube ich wäre
allerdings diesen
teil das sie an der seite werde ich noch
ein bisschen offener machen bzw dass
hier auch noch mal weg das können wir
alles generell noch ein bisschen
verändern hier aber das soll ja auch
nicht so komplett jetzt steil wie die
niagarafälle runter gehen so hier vorne
noch beim beziehen ich glaube ich auch
wieder so ein bisschen was drauf gibt
das hier so ein bisschen schöner lang
hier das mache ich mal weg hier so ein
bisschen so du weg und sagt was wir auch
noch machen wollte was schon gemacht
habe waren hier die banner weg diese
sahen wirklich nicht so gut aus wir
können noch einmal ganz kurz
nun würde ich allerdings sagen machen
wir weiter mit unserem kleinen fluss
hier vorne die truppen fische setzen
noch rein hatte ich gerade vergessen
nicht hier einmal die axt rausgeholt
beziehungsweise kurz die schaufel und
jetzt einmal hier alles abbauen ich weiß
auch gar nicht ob wir das ganze
zuckerrohr jedoch brauchen was sie alles
steht aber lieber haben halt nicht haben
sage ich immer ganz bekannter spruch von
mir vorne erde rein und dann machen wir
jetzt hier einfach mal alles ein
bisschen durcheinander voll mit
verschiedenen blöcken genauso wie bei
unserem so das alles hier so ein
bisschen zusammen passt also hier zum
beispiel noch ein coup ist ohnehin
diorit ich mal ganz großen teil im netz
so ich habe jetzt einfach mal hier
überall noch so ein bisschen stufen
hingesetzt ein bisschen seegras seetang
bisschen famose stufen grobe erde hier
vorne und ich habe das ganze herunter
gezogen bis hier vorne ins wasser rein
so dass das dass man halt wirklich
erkennt okay das hier ist der wasserfall
wasserfälle haben die ansicht dass sie
die wasserfälle aussieht ich habe ich
auch gerade dazu entschieden hier vorne
das komplette zuckerrohr ein warmer zu
fällen
die sache ist nämlich dass ich so viel
davon habe und ich weiß ich hatte vor
ein paar folgenden projekt das problem
dass ich fast gar kein zuckerrohr hatte
aber da braucht deshalb auch unbedingt
für die bücherregale was derzeit vom
tisch ist weil wir die bücherregale er
davor auf unserer zauberinsel komplett
vollständig stehen haben und ich finde
sie so deutlich schöner aussicht jetzt
mal ganz kurz das bauen will und geht so
ein bisschen über die passagen weil da
hinten ist auch das gras neu gewachsen
für jeden fall gehe ich hier nochmal mit
dem bau mir daran hier vorne auch hier
auch nochmal hier vorne das ist alles
schon zu groß geworden wie schnell das
jetzt einfach ging hier nochmals tag und
hier
ich habe auf jeden fall auch die
knochendichte mitgenommen das heißt
damit können auch noch ein bisschen
merkt noch mehr machen die haben wir aus
dem netz und hier auch nochmal so ein
bisschen drüber gehen damit alles ein
bisschen verrucht aussieht wenn das
extrem schön
ich weiß nicht was ich hier von jetzt
noch nicht gemacht habe bahnstrecke
schaaf wohl okay geben wir ganz schöne
menge noch nicht ich gehe aber auf jeden
fall trotz noch immer schnell mit dem
ball einmal drüber
ihr merkt auch schon ich habe für die
heutige insel reparatur kein dich wenn
ich noch mal eben kurz währen sagt ich
brauche nämlich die ganze rote wolle für
meinen leuchtturm den ich ja auch noch
auf bucket list habe für dieses projekt
es tut mir leid weil ich gerade sagen
dass ich für die heutige episode keine
fragen vorbereitet habe ich habe erst
gedacht
will ich fragen vorbereiten möchte ich
fragen raussuchen die mir gestellt habt
dann wäre es natürlich ein cooleres eine
coolere insel reparatur folge geworden
glaube ich wenn ich noch ein paar fragen
eingegangen wäre die sache ist
allerdings was ich mir dann gedacht habe
und deswegen habe ich meinen youtube
beitrag wieder gelöscht ruhig meinte
stellt man mit ein paar fragen
ich dachte mir nämlich einfach ich
glaube ich bin produktiver wenn ich
keine fragen aber auch die ich eingehen
weil ich weiß dass ich überhaupt nicht
die sache ist nicht nur die daten
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht mensch
kommen mache ich das mal lieber ohne
fragen heute du bleibst stehen weil ich
gerade keine angst dabei habe aber sonst
würde ich sagen haben wir es eigentlich
relativ krass hier ist jetzt alles schön
wenn ich nur mal eben kurz abfällen
das hier ist ein schöner aus hier die
hundehütte steht noch hier das ganze zu
gehören nämlich mal mit sie werde so ein
bisschen zucker kann ich auch stehen
lassen an den seiten das sieht
eigentlich ganz schön aus guck mal hier
das was ich stehen aber hier vorne
runter das musste ich wirklich nicht
sein beziehungsweise nur so ein bisschen
das reicht ja schon hier unten hin sagte
nämlich mit hier setze ich ein hin und
da ich lasse ich mal stehen hier vorne
der baum bleibt stehen dem grab dass wir
nicht ganz schön hier und hier der hier
die nämlich auch mal wieder weg heißt da
kann ich auch noch mal kurz drauf gehen
hier vorne aber noch mal mit mir hier
vorne könnte ich noch mal ein bisschen
was machen es ist so schwierig so etwas
zu kommentieren und ich hoffe dass ich
die folge gefällt auch wenn wir heute
nicht spannendes irgendwie zu erleben
haben aber sowas finde ich auch ganz
wichtig in diesem projekt das wir
einfach auf unsere insel so ein bisschen
nach theben und uns darum auch so ein
bisschen kümmern
ich finde es hier noch mal eben schnell
noch mal eben kurz auf meine liste was
ich jetzt noch nicht gemacht habe
beziehungsweise was auf jeden fall noch
geschehen muss also die bahnstrecke gott
ich muss erst mal steine farben
[Musik]
ja es ist entspannt 5 jemanden aus zwei
blöcken kann man mal machen
ich gehe nach unten für steine und finde
wieder nur die erwarten
[Musik]
ich hoffe mal dass die menge an
bruchstein reicht ich hab jetzt
dreieinhalb stacks abgebaut also
insgesamt 200 blöcke ich weiß es der
komplette weg den wir rüber gehen müssen
über 300 blöcke lang ist aber ich habe
ja auch schon ein bisschen was gebaut
deswegen vielleicht kommen wir damit hin
ich werde jetzt auf jeden fall mal kurz
nach oben gehen bzw
ich denke ich einfach wieder ganz kurz
da time lab sein denn das ist einfach
die time labs folge heute also in der
reparatur sachen dialekt hat sie ja
nicht die ganze zeit angucken
[Musik]
und leute die schweiz hier
zehn sekunden später und läutet wächst
ihr egal
das kannst du doch nicht bringen man das
kann doch nicht sein
[Musik]
wir haben es geschafft freunde wir sind
hier vorne auf dem festland angekommen
ich werde noch mal ganz kurz mehr glück
spitzhacke nehme mir ein bisschen kohle
mitnehmen dass bei einem block bis jetzt
nicht so krass belohnt allerdings haben
wir es geschafft wir sind hier auf dem
festland angekommen vielleicht könnt ihr
euch noch daran erinnern wir haben ja
hier rechts in den bergen die eine
kranke höhle gefunden und da hinten
haben wir die dinge gefunden die
kürbisse die wir dann gebraucht haben
für unsere reisen co
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wo ist eigentlich ich würde jetzt
allerdings sagen wir laufen erst mal
zurück zu unserer kleinen heimatinsel
ihr seht schon hier ich bin mf5 modus
und da hinten müssen wir auf jeden fall
hin hier müssen überall noch schienen
hin wenn ich nach vorne laufe hier seht
ihr dort befindet sich meine bude also
dahin meine bude und hier hinten das
festland das ist schon eine gehörige
lange entfernung die geht es dann auch
schon langsam wieder los mit den rails
also wir müssen hier wirklich noch eine
menge eisen zusammensparen und auch noch
eine menge gold wenn wir brauchen ja die
antriebs schienen so dass unsere lore
lka unser ece natürlich hier vernünftig
drüber fährt hier vorne kommen dann die
ressort fackeln immer drauf mit den
antriebs schienen das werde ich alles in
der nächsten folge machen denn ich bin
hier bei über zwei stunden
ich hoffe euch hat die heutige episode
insel reparatur 20 gefallen schaue ich
mal an die cool das jetzt schon aussieht
weil wir überall einfach das dingens ist
überall gras ist knochen habe ich jetzt
nicht mit dabei deswegen lassen wir das
jetzt einfach mal so aber es sieht auf
jeden fall schon deutlich cooler aus
finde ich alles ich habe alle löcher zu
gemacht es sind natürlich auch hier und
da hinten neue dazugekommen durch die
kripo was sagst du dazu schafft perfekt
die wolle vom schaf nämlich trotzdem mal
noch mit die brauche ich zwar nicht
direkt für die nächste folge die
übermorgen bei online geht sondern für
eine der über nächsten folgen oder so
werde ich hier hinten den leuchtturm
draufsetzen möchte so ein bisschen als
wahrzeichen so dass wir immer unsere
insel wieder finden in der nächsten
folge geht es erstmal um unsere stand
villa da wenn ich jetzt mal ganz kurze
schild nehmen das dahin platzieren also
hier ein schild hin mit strandvilla
beziehungsweise strandhaus nicom
strandvilla wir wissen auf jeden fall
was sie machen wollen und das werden wir
definitiv in der nächsten folge machten
noch einmal ganz kurz zusammengefasst
was wir heute geschafft haben wir haben
unsere komplette insel ein bisschen
china gemacht was den strand angeht das
haben wir von der vorne vom stall rom
gezogen bis hier vorne zum wasserfall in
den wasserfall haben wir auch ein
bisschen cooler gemacht wir haben die
das vorweg genommen wir haben hier
überall die steine eingesetzt um das
seegras das sieht sehr nice ausfindig
wir haben fische in unseren serie
eingesetzt sind die hier überhaupt noch
drin die sind die gleich mehr drin
aber das schildkröten für die fische
schießen der verqueren hier vorne
einfällt gepflanzt gewachsen ist
mittlerweile sogar schon hier die
kürbisse können wir auch im kurz ab und
sackt die melone hier nehme ich auch mal
wieder mit diese melone und den anderen
kürbis auch die rote beete müsste glaube
ich auch gewachsen sein ich habe
wirklich keine ahnung was mit rote beete
machen sollen oben steht neue rezepte
verfügbar aber ich weiß nicht also ich
hasse rote beete keine ahnung ob ihr da
irgendwie eine idee habt die kann ich
dann nicht ersetzen sondern die rote
bietet samen sagt vielleicht sind die
fürs brauen ja wichtig ich würde
allerdings sagen dass wir auf jeden fall
noch eine menge anderer kram sachen hier
geschafft haben haben da hinten die
insel ein bisschen abgetragen das hier
weil hin gepackt wir haben die löcher
hinten zugemacht wir haben ganz ganz
ganz ganz viel geschafft auch hier mit
dem räucherofen und so ich geh jetzt
schlafen lassen daumen hoch und ein
video da wenn es euch gefallen hat wird
mich sehr freuen wenn noch kein abonnent
seitig liegt auf abonnieren
er verpasst keine videos mehr und wenn
ich schon aber dennoch die glocke kommt
eine benachrichtigung wenn ich etwas
neues hochladen
es wird übermorgen das nächste mal der
fall sein ich hoffe euch hat diese xxl
insel reparatur folge 20 gefallen sind
und übermorgen am mittwoch um 20 uhr
wieder wenn ich meine strandbilder bauen
[Musik]